were there any limits that you placed on
screen time just barney i think that was
a cult i love you you love me i'm t i'm
adam and we are dads to nine month old
twins rev sky and this week i tried
parenting like my boomer parents no
technology no face time and relying only
on instinct this week i traveled to
nebraska to visit my parents i took rev
sky with me t stayed in chicago for a
bit my brother and i drove the 450 mile
road trip to get here while i was here
since my parents always have a ton of
advice we were like hey why don't we try
me parenting like a boomer for a whole
week see how it goes we are somewhere in
iowa
giving the girls
their bottles got uncle david here
they've been pretty good so far just
took a nap now we're getting some food
in them gonna change their diapers
stretch them out a little
and get back on the road we are
officially in the home stretch girls are
doing pretty well i made it heading home
to see mimsy and grandpa
adam and the kids are gone they are
in nebraska
i miss them so
much but let me tell you this
i miss them
but i am having a good time as well in
the 80s there was maybe
a little less worry about every little
thing just the simplicity of when it was
in the 80s and versus now because now
it's like you can't do this you can't do
that it's like oh my god they are kids
they're going to be fine hanging out in
nebraska with my mom and
my niece ainslie the girls are still
taking a nap we're coming right up on 11
30 which is normally
what time they wake up from their nap
they sleep for about an hour and a half
and if they go past that then we will
wake them up to keep them on schedule so
when it came to nap time my mom's
whole thing is never wake a sleeping
baby which i was going along with
thinking that they would you know wake
up within a certain amount of time like
close to when they normally wake up and
they just kept sleeping it's 11 35 and
it's really slowly killing me inside
that we're not waking the girls up but
we're doing it because we're what
we're boomers okay it's 11 45. i said 20
minutes we're doing 15 minutes this is
we're just asking for trouble with this
so that was one time where i had to be
like enough
waking them up they are up from their
extended nap and they seem to be in a
very good mood so uh
i mean i would be in a good mood too if
i got to sleep all day but then what
would happen i wouldn't be able to sleep
at night right one of the things that
i'm doing is getting
canned baby food up to this point all
they've had is like freshly cooked food
that we've made for them they actually
had a lot of choices they had sweet
potatoes they had carrots and peas one
of their choices was sweet potato and
chicken just the idea of like
room temperature canned chicken i just
i'm sure it's fine but i just couldn't
do that to my girls so we're doing
canned green beans and before i feed it
to my girls i have to taste it myself
i never did that
i hope they like it more than i do i was
actually nervous for them because i
thought they were just gonna reject it
[Music]
well it's not a rejection so we'll take
it as a success so even though this
isn't something that we normally do i
think it's still pretty good we still
went organic on it
even though my parents didn't do organic
i don't even know if they had organic
back jars the day we like chemicals
extra chemicals there you go
they ate the whole thing they loved it
we're gonna do jarred baby food from now
on
yeah i don't think so
it's like the house is so quiet
you don't hear anything nothing at all
no kids crying
no one running around like nothing
it is late it's like 11
45 just wrapping up the day
usually i finish the day by like
cleaning up the kitchen and making sure
everything's
set for the next day since i am
parenting like a boomer this week
i cannot use the dishwasher to clean the
bottles
and we always have
a hefty hall of bottles at the end of
the day so
about to
use
any little bottle brush washing all the
bottles by hand is a chore after having
our dishwasher routine down it was just
like a nightmare it's so much work oh
god i'm becoming my dad i'm wearing
sandals with socks this boomer thing is
really
taking its toll one of the life savers
for me and t has been this
like automatic formula bottle making
machine you just choose the ounce you
want choose the temperature you want
push a button and it makes it takes like
10 seconds but the way that i did it
this week was
you like get out the can of formula you
scoop it into the bottle which already
has the measured amount of water in it
and then you heat up a separate cup of
water and fill it up with water
microwave it till it's boiling
and you immerse the bottle
so that it can heat the formula to a
temperature that the girls will accept
but it can't be too hot applying it to
the wrist
and it's cold back into the hot water
and it took forever this is torture test
number two onto the wrist
oh that's body temp we're ready to go
like bathing hygiene and all that what
did you do you boys got a bath every
single day shampooed your hair bathed
you we used baby magic and then you got
lotioned up afterwards we normally use
tubby tot or keels or some nice baby
shampoo body wash it's bath time with uh
the boomer soap here we go johnson's
baby shampoo it's a classic as gentle to
eyes as pure as water this is not a paid
endorsement so we're going to try that
tonight instead of
the fancy stuff that we normally use
when i was growing up my mom used the
same soap she used on herself there's no
nothing that is for kids everything is
for human being all right girls it's
time to call papa normally we would
facetime him but since this is
the week where i'm parenting like my
boomer parents
we're gonna call him over the phone no
video papa's on the phone say hi
[Applause]
well i guess that means they miss you
[Music]
yep
[Music]
okay let's turn on facetime instant
gratification
yeah mom was like too much instant
gratification you're teaching them bad
habits blah blah blah blah blah and they
want to see their dad what are you going
to do here's papa
hello getting ready to put the girls to
bed my boomer parents said that
they did not use sleep sacks at all we
use sleep sacks to help the girls sleep
a sleep sack is sort of a zip up blanket
almost that you just cover them in the
ones we use are actually weighted kind
of like a weighted blanket and so that
also the pressure is supposed to help
them feel like secure or touched or
something never had sleep sex when they
were babies we had we swaddled them and
when they got older we just had them in
warmer pajamas how'd that work for you
uh you made it did you guys use like
white noise or anything uh i snore
and what about
baby monitors i think we had like a
walkie-talkie thing no video do you
still have any baby monitors probably
but i don't throw things away another
thing that a lot of boomers don't do
the og
baby monitor that's our normal baby
monitor with the video
and all that wi-fi function and then
here's
this old one okay so i think it's on i
think it's working
we used to pick up our next door
neighbors we can hear everything they
said there's also a spy device all i can
hear is their white noise
i'm hoping that as they cry
so when it came to putting the girls in
front of the tv for the first time that
was definitely a step for me uh we
turned on pbs i think and
they were both super into it as we knew
they would be i mean when we have the tv
on they try to watch it and we just stop
them but this one we're like okay here
you go you can watch tv so i feel like
it was sort of like candy for them they
were very into it were there any limits
that you placed on screen time
just barney i think that was a cult i
love you you love me
i loved barney yeah well that was
limited the girls don't get any screen
time that's something that adam and i
have decided from the beginning that we
are not doing screen time for the girls
probably until they are two the most
screen time they get is when they're
face timing
my parents or friends or family we've
noticed that the times where we have the
tv on
and they start watching it if we'll call
their name or do anything they like are
so zoned in on the tv that like we can't
get their attention and it's like ah
this is why we're not doing it another
boomer pro tip is keeping them
entertained with random kitchen
tupperware
and utensils
got some rubber spatulas here they've
been loving
the happiest they've seemed all day
entertaining the girls with bowls and
utensils we have tried once or twice at
home they were so into it i think it
kept them busy for like 45 minutes it's
safe effective inexpensive i've been
parenting like my boomer parents all
week
it is exhausting i don't know if it's
because
the boomer lifestyle is exhausting or if
it's just because
parenting twin nine-month-old girls is a
lot i have no idea how they did it like
it's just
wild the bottles alone putting all the
formula in the bottles every time you
have to make it and heating it manually
like that
wild it is about seven in the morning i
just went to the airport to go catch my
flight to go see the kids i am extremely
excited and i can't wait to get there so
when i get to adam's parents house and
adam greeted me at the door with plaid
shirt high rise pants and these socks
[Music]
just got the girls up from a nap it's
their first time seeing the papa in
a week you ready to see them
[Music]
you guys got so big
i missed you
[Music]
the 80s were a simpler time and i
learned a ton about patience this week i
took a lot of good things away from it
but when it comes to twins like
technology just makes things so much
easier and we are not waiting to warm up
bottles those girls will not make it i
don't think we would make it
[Music]